[Music]
[Applause]
the who's taller game Justin Herbert or
Matt Ryan Matt Ryan joined us in the
first hour of the program
who is taller yes Paul now we're going
to go back to the college bios because
sometimes those are more true
are they
supposedly I do you want to bet on it
Matt Ryan seems taller yeah I'm going to
say Matt Ryan is an inch and a half
taller than Justin Herbert wow okay I
you met them both yes we have kicked it
with both of them Justin's got you know
like a puffy hair though so it may seem
a little taller good less these days
yeah Matt has less Moss okay Paul okay
Justin can settle this but I have Matt
Ryan listed six five at BC I have just
enlisted at six six at org whoa holy
smoke okay let's uh try to confirm that
Justin Herbert Chargers quarterback
what's the official height there Justin
hey what's going on guys it uh it is six
foot six so that is accurate
were you worried that you were too tall
or that the scouts would say you were
too tall perception-wise
um that is something that crossed my
mind I I don't think it was that
important though
um I thought the film and you know how
you threw the ball was was more
important so that was definitely
something I continued to work on but uh
something I wasn't too worried about all
right what hurts today after that win
definitely a tough font win and those
are hard to come by in the NFL so we'll
take any that we can get and uh the
body's a little sore but uh you know it
feels much better after a win
you don't throw a touchdown pass I think
the first time in what 27 games
but you do win and I mentioned this we
never look back on ugly wins we always
look back on ugly losses but
um how do you how do you guys as a team
go let's just forget about it when do
you watch the film on this by the way
and then you know how quickly do you
move on to Seattle
yeah we'll watch it this morning and um
you know I thought there were a lot of
good parts of the game you know things
that we did well on offense and defense
and um you know forced to turn over on
special teams as well and that was big
for us we moved the ball well and and we
converted on third downs and didn't put
up enough points
um you know we'd love to be able to
finish in the Red Zone with touchdowns
instead of field goals but that's kind
of the way the game went and you know
the Broncos they have an incredible
defense and we kind of knew that was the
game going into it
um and so you know we're thankful for
the the defense and the Special Teams
coming up with some big stops and some
big plays um ultimately giving us the
win there when when Dustin Hopkins comes
out there for that field goal in
overtime like what do you what are you
thinking when you turn it over to him
and he's injured limping out there on
one leg
he's tough he's incredibly tough and um
you know we've got so much respect for
that guy and the way he shows up every
day to work and uh he's a professional
and and going through as much pain as he
did and to be able to cake like he did
um there was never a doubt with him
could you have kicked it like who's the
backup kicker
JK Scott would be the backup kicker um
you know he did some kickoffs last night
um for Dustin but uh both those guys are
talented special kickers and uh very
thankful that we have them on our team
are you an emergency kicker
um I haven't kicked in a long time I was
a High School kicker but uh I don't
think I'd be ready to to handle that
challenge well I don't know you know you
you have to do things that other
quarterbacks don't do let's you know
let's see Josh Allen do this
it would definitely be a challenge going
out there and kicking and um especially
not using a pat pad to get the ball off
the ground so that's something I got to
get used to and and get a couple
practice reps in before I try how much
football did you watch on Sunday
a ton of it you know we started out with
a walk through and some some meetings
here and then kind of had the afternoon
off so to kind of go over the game plan
and um just had football going on in the
background and um you know it's always
great to check up on other teams and
just kind of see uh what's going around
the league so it's always good to watch
football who fascinates you
um shoot there are a bunch of
quarterbacks in this league that you
know I've got a ton of respect for uh
Patrick Mahomes Tom Brady Josh Allen Joe
burrow those guys are talented special
players and on any chance you get to
watch those guys you're gonna be able to
pick up something from their game okay
what have you picked up
um you know I think it's just all about
competing uh being a competitor and
putting your team in the best position
to win and you know it might not always
be a pretty game but they're they're
going to find a way to move the ball
convert on third Downs
um and get their team the Red Zone score
um and just ultimately win
any difference between playing a day
game and a night game for you
um
I've always enjoyed playing the night
games and just kind of under the lights
as I thought of has always been a really
cool moment and you know I kind of hate
waiting throughout the day just to go
play so that's kind of why the early
names are fun to me too but uh both are
great opportunities to go play football
do you subscribe to I gotta get popped
once to really feel like now the game
started
uh that's a good question I I think
that's kind of one of those things that
um definitely gets you going early on in
the game if you get hit and you realize
you know what all right we're back into
it I can handle this
um I can take that shot and I can keep
rolling and um you know I think that's
definitely something the running backs
feel uh especially but uh definitely
something that comes up
because it's so violent I I always tell
people if you watch the game from the
sidelines you'd never let your kids play
football because of the it's like car
crashes
it uh it is definitely a tough sport to
watch sometimes and um I've got so much
respect for the offensive lineman the
linebackers the running backs the guy
that go at each other every single play
I don't know if my body could physically
handle that
um and so I've got all the more respect
for those guys to be able to do that
every play we had Matt Ryan on first
hour and he said he'd be up for Replay
for the roughing the passer now you know
he said that the worst part is when they
land on you it's not the hit as much as
when they land on you
what do you think of that yeah that's
that's definitely the tough part about
those hits is
um you know those are really fast strong
athletic guys falling on top of you and
um you know it never feels good to be
able to get hit in the ribs or or the
lungs or anything like that and
um you know it's all about just being
safe and getting the ball out quickly as
you can making sure you don't take as
many hits as you can
well congrats on the win and uh if you
need any more football is fun shirts for
the family you let us know I'm more than
happy to send them your way
I appreciate that I've got plenty of my
family so I think they're covered but uh
always a pleasure thank you all right
that's Justin Herbert they host Seattle
on Sunday taking down the Broncos last
night
Todd has to now say goodbye to Justin
Herbert
he didn't say have a good season you did
not say have a good season to Justin
Herbert there when you said goodbye I
did not say have a good season I said be
well I said appreciate the time it's
hard to say you normally you normally
good luck this season have a good season
you didn't say that I'm usually very
super too friendly but a direct
competitor to the Broncos it's like yeah
break a leg I mean that that's a few
practices uh skip a walk through yeah
break a few ribs oh maybe you already
have